[Music]
billy eilish's road to the 2021 grammys
the 19 year old is up for four awards
three of those for her smash hit
everything i wanted
including song of the year record of the
year and pop solo performance
it's called everything i wanted but we
called it nightmare for a while
[Applause]
when billy and i write songs together
we're having to
write lyrics that we can both identify
with so that we can continue the
narrative
phineas came up with as long as i'm here
no one can hurt you
we decided to make it about our
relationship
and how we help each other and like deal
with things together
it just completely like paved the way
for the rest of the song
billy co-wrote the song with her brother
phineas and she directed
the song's music video that's supple for
her smell
i love that billy is also nominated for
song written for visual media for her
james bond theme
no time to die
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she said this about the song to e.t at
last year's grammys
youngest person ever to be doing a james
bond theme
like what can you tease for us about
what that song's gonna be
what can i tease
i don't know if i got anything for you
you kind of just gotta wait it's
it just is what it is it's good
it was also that night that she scooped
up her first grammys
five to be exact it's like the craziest
thing in the world so i'm so grateful to
be here for real
but let's be honest billy's always been
destined for musical greatness
are you ready for that next level of
super stardom
no no i think i am honestly no i think i
i feel like i feel like i am
i feel like i always have been a little
bit without really realizing it
your destiny a little
you